y
[Música]
cómo vivir selenski el presidente de
ucrania está dispuesto a negociar con
vladimir putin pero sin ultimátum
mientras que el mandatario ruso insiste
en que occidente es el más afectado con
las sanciones económicas que le han
impuesto a rusia tendremos reportes de
ucrania
el presidente y el primer ministro de
finlandia anunciaron que el país nórdico
debería solicitar la membresía en la
otan y rusia respondió que esto lo
obligaría a tomar realidad técnicos
militares en su contra
además suecia también considera la
posibilidad de romper su neutralidad
analizaremos en esta emisión
eeuu se convirtió en el primer país del
mundo en superar el millón de muertos
por kobe 19 el congreso y el presidente
de bailén le rindieron un homenaje a las
víctimas mientras que el mandatario
pidió mejorar las cadenas de suministro
de vacunas para prevenir futuras
pandemias
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda de nuevo maría clara calle
empezamos en ucrania el presidente de
volodymyr selenski dijo que está
dispuesto a negociar con su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin pero advirtió que
sin ultimátum insistió además en el
intercambio del que ha hablado quien
para sacar militares atrapados en la
acería de us of talent mariupol y agregó
que suiza y turquía están en las
negociaciones por otro lado putin volvió
a afirmar que occidente es el más
afectado por las sanciones económicas en
su contra
esto
es obvio que debido a las leyes
económicas subjetivas al continuar con
la obsesión de las sanciones
inevitablemente lleva a consecuencias
complejas y difíciles de revertir para
la unión europea y sus ciudadanos
soy un switch r si a rusia se las
arregla con confianza frente a los
desafíos externos gracias tanto a la
política macroeconómica responsable de
los últimos años como a las decisiones
sistemáticas para fortalecer la
soberanía económica tecnológica y la
seguridad alimentaria
la producción de alimentos en ucrania ha
sido uno de los sectores más golpeados
por la guerra el ministerio de
agricultura informó que lo que va del
año se ha sembrado un 25 por ciento
menos que en 2021 y al menos 25 millones
de toneladas de granos no han podido ser
exportadas según la fao nuestra enviada
especial catalina gómez ángel visitó la
ciudad de bach mut en la región
separatista de donges donde los
campesinos no han podido recoger al
menos un tercio del trigo y del maíz
esto por los bombardeos y el fuego
cruzado una de las grandes consecuencias
que tiene esta guerra por la región del
donbass como en el resto de ucrania
tiene que ver con las consecuencias para
la agricultura hablábamos esta mañana
con uno de los directores de una de las
empresas más grandes de estas regiones
yo rentan
a pequeños campesinos si tienen en su
poder 30 mil hectáreas que cultivan con
trigo y con maíz nos contaban que en
este momento es un tercio de esas
tierras no van a poder recoger la
cosecha ya sea porque están en
territorios disputados o en control de
las fuerzas rusas pero nos decía que
ellos no son los únicos que trabajan
aquí hay otra compañía por ejemplo la
provincia de lugansk con más de 80 mil
hectáreas que ya están en poder de las
fuerzas enemigas pero no solamente les
preocupa eso sino las reservas que
tienen de grano en los depósitos no las
han podido sacar de la región porque las
carreteras son muy malas y no tienen
gasolina y les preocupa que en un caso
en un escenario en el que las fuerzas
rusas avanzarán tomaran el control de
estas reservas que son fundamentales
para ucrania desde que rusia invadió a
ucrania el 24 de febrero decenas de
miles de rusos decidieron exiliarse
huyendo de los efectos económicos y
sociales del conflicto pero muchos
consideran que no están recibiendo la
ayuda ni la acogida que requieren para
una vida digna en contraste con el apoyo
que han tenido los ucranianos
como muchos otros rusos artyon kotenko
diseñador gráfico de 50 años optó por el
exilio tras el inicio de la invasión
rusa ucrania y horrorizado por la guerra
llegó a la vecina finlandia hasta
alcanzar su destino final parís
y
estaba en shock por la guerra estaba
perdido no podía vivir ni respirar y el
hecho de salir aquí a la calle de ver
que otra vida es posible de ver a la
gente tocar música encontrarse
intercambiar seguir dibujando en las
paredes
eso me curó mía en ingenieros habria
muñiz coimera pero la realidad que tengo
encontró al llegar a la capital francesa
no cuadraba con lo que había imaginado
pronto le quedó claro que encontrar
trabajo iba a ser muy difícil a
diferencia de lo que ocurre con los
refugiados ucranianos que la mayor parte
de europa acoge con los brazos abiertos
entiendo bien que en esta situación no
tenemos derecho a pedir nada pero eso no
va a impedir nada cada vez van a venir
más personas como yo y tenemos que
darles la oportunidad de trabajar
oficialmente y expedir visados
humanitarios se puede documentar no
habido en las semanas posteriores a la
invasión decenas de miles de rusos
abandonaron su país por miedo a las
sanciones económicas ya una posible
movilización militar triste esto es
catastrófico y hay que hacer algo de lo
contrario los rusos solo serán ilegales
los ciudadanos rusos también sufren los
efectos de lo que putin denomina como
una operación especial forzados a
participar en un conflicto que no
decidieron y objetos de prejuicios en
repetidas ocasiones
finlandia y suecia están cada vez más
cerca de pertenecer a la otan los
líderes finlandeses se pronunciaron el
jueves a favor de solicitar el ingreso a
la alianza militar y los políticos
suecos están considerando lo mismo si lo
hacen esto rompería con la tradicional
neutralidad que han mantenido ambas
naciones nórdicas ante el anuncio de
finlandia el kremlin respondió con
amenazas diciendo que se verá obligado a
tomar medidas técnicos militares
analizamos el tema con fausto pretelín
muñoz él fue profesor en el departamento
de estudios internacionales del
instituto tecnológico autónomo de méxico
bienvenido a france 24
rusia alega que él de la otan hasta un
país fronterizo como finlandia amenaza
su seguridad y viola uno de los pactos
de la guerra fría de que occidente no
llevaría a sus militares hasta allí que
significa entonces geopolíticamente si
estos dos países se incorporan a la otan
y aclara buenas noches bueno que
significa evidentemente es un golpe muy
fuerte en contra de rusia del presidente
ruso es un segundo elemento quizás
después de la cuestión de las sanciones
la cuestión de los 27 miembros en
europea en contra de rusia esto
significa evidentemente que la otan está
viva que la otan se está renovando que
la otan ya no está con una muerte
cerebral como lo dijo el presidente de
macrón hace un par de años y esto pues
evidentemente fue una mala noticia para
el presidente insisto creo que es un
síntoma de lo mal que está saliendo
para el presidente ruso y por el otro
lado qué tan grande es el riesgo que
enfrentan finlandia y suiza y suecia de
un posible ataque de los rusos como para
quebrar con su historial de neutralidad
es un escenario difícil complejo porque
un presidente arrinconado como el
presidente ruso podría hacer uso de
armas
más allá de que haga uso de las armas
nucleares pueden llegar a tener
conflictos tanto con finlandia como con
suecia hay que recordar media clara que
fue si el día de ayer también avisó que
reino unido va a ser un paraguas para
suecia en caso de que sea atacada esto
es con un preámbulo de que pueda llegar
también a
solicitar la adhesión a la otan y
hablemos de nuevo de la otan y no sólo
de este preámbulo que usted nos menciona
y cuéntenos una vez los países muestren
su voluntad de ingresar a la alianza
militar qué pasos siguen para que la
decisión se materialice
tuvimos problemas de conexión con
nuestro invitado nosotros seguimos con
las noticias y es que continúan los
reclamos por la exclusión de cuba
nicaragua y venezuela de la cumbre de
las américas hoy se sumó el ex
presidente del gobierno español josé
luís rodríguez zapatero durante su viaje
a bolivia le pidió a eeuu que es el
organizador del evento que reflexione
sobre su postura rodríguez zapatero
señaló que la carta de las naciones
unidas no distinguen regímenes políticos
anteriormente los presidentes de méxico
y de bolivia andrés manuel lópez obrador
y luis arse afirmaron que no acudirían a
la cumbre que se realizará en junio en
los ángeles si la casa blanca no invita
a todos los países de la región
podemos recuperar la señal con nuestro
invitado para continuar hablando de la
otan estábamos preguntando si una vez
los países suecia y finlandia deciden
incorporarse a la otan que pasó son los
que siguen para que esta decisión quede
en pie
bueno a diferencia de lo que es la
inglesa europea el ingreso a la otan es
mucho más rápido más sencillo es decir
una firma de un tratado atlántico en el
cual estos países se comprometen a pues
adherir los compromisos particularmente
financieros y de armas y de estrategias
son tres elementos que de alguna manera
sí contemplan los tratados de la alianza
atlántica norte que bueno ya cumplen
bastantes décadas después de la después
de la segunda guerra mundial pero
insisto creo que va a ser muy rápido ya
el secretario general de la otan el día
de hoy dijo que va a ser eso va a ser lo
más dinámico posible el próximo domingo
por la tarde finlandia avisará
formalmente que sugiere adherirse a la
otan y si ellos se unen la seguridad de
la región estaría en riesgo
como está ahora actualmente creo que
depende efectivamente de el presidente
putin él tiene la llave para concluir o
no esta guerra o esta invasión que
inició contra ucrania pero evidentemente
si da muestras de una enorme molestia en
contra de finlandia y posiblemente de
suecia por este tipo de adhesiones sabe
muy bien que el enemigo es la otan pero
también la otra guerra indirecta es con
la unión europea y las dos las está
perdiendo señor pretelín gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24
buenas noches y cambiamos de noticia
eeuu superó el millón de muertos por
kobe 19 este jueves en el marco de la
segunda cumbre mundial sobre el
coronavirus el presidente joe biden
lamentó la cifra e instó a coordinar
ayuda internacional para prevenir
futuras pandemias
bandera a media asta en la casa blanca
un gesto que se repitió en los edificios
públicos de todo el país por haber
alcanzado el millón de muertos por kobe
la pandemia no ha acabado hoy alcanzamos
un trágico hito aquí en eeuu un millón
de muertes por kobe de un millón de
sillas vacías alrededor de la mesa
familiar cada una de ellas perdidas y
reemplazables insustituibles faison
los
eeuu es el país del mundo con más
fallecidos por el virus y aunque lejos
quedan los días de calles vacías y
hospitales desbordados el país aún tiene
una materia pendiente poco más del 65
por ciento de la población está vacunada
por completo de sobre lesionada presión
en este verano es una oportunidad para
renovar nuestros esfuerzos para seguir
acelerando con el fin de tener esta
pandemia bajo control y prevenir futuras
crisis
crisis bailén pidió hoy al congreso
estadounidense aprobar una partida de 10
mil millones de dólares para prevenir
futuras pandemias un esfuerzo para el
que evaden ha instado al resto de países
de la segunda sobre el 19 celebrada este
jueves alemania ha sido uno de los
primeros en responder al llamado
apoyamos su propuesta ha querido joe de
establecer un nuevo fondo en el banco
mundial para la preparación ante una
pandemia que opere en estrecha
coordinación y cooperación con la o&m s
fitch
alemania contribuirá inicialmente con 50
millones de euros china declinó la
participación en medio de la polémica
por su política de kobe cero con duras
cuarentenas frente a los nuevos rebrotes
en el país la fiscalía de guatemala
pidió retirarle la inmunidad al ministro
de agricultura por una denuncia de
corrupción que había solicitado
eeuu en la presunta malversación de más
de 200.000 dólares a la par se emitieron
14 órdenes de captura de los presuntos
implicados en esta trama de corrupción
previamente desde guatemala nuestro
corresponsal
andrés suárez nos explicó de qué se
trata este caso por el que acusan a uno
de los ministros de hoy el gobierno de
alejandro giammatei sufre un fuerte
revés sobre todo porque el ministro de
agricultura josé ángel lópez se le ha
solicitado la fiscalía del ministerio
público ha solicitado retirarle la
inmunidad esto como usted comentaba en
un caso de presunta corrupción
denunciado por los estados a través de
hoffman
jason y sobre todo con fondos que usáis
le habría dado al país guatemalteco en
el año 2016 para ejecutar servicios
financieros a las comunidades lópez en
el 2016 el ministro de agricultura era
el directivo de una organización que
tenía la necesidad de ejecutar estos
dineros y se le acusa a él ya otras 14
personas específicamente de haberlos
malversados de manera tal que la
fiscalía el ministerio público emitió
hoy 14 órdenes de arresto realizando 27
allanamientos y ya cinco personas han
sido capturadas pero si se le retira la
inmunidad al ministro podría ser también
arrestado y
judicializado pero por qué ocurre tres
años después de que los eeuu hubiese
hecho esta denuncia básicamente porque
la fiscalía en próximos días está
próxima a saberse el nombre de quién va
a ser su nuevo director o directora
alejandro giammatei debe elegir entre
seis preseleccionados donde está el
nombre de consuelo porras la actual
fiscal que se señala es la escudera de
llamada en presuntos casos de corrupción
y que el propio eeuu la acusa de
encubrir investigaciones de corrupción
los incendios forestales en california
eeuu llegaron hasta mansiones
multimillonarias
los residentes de 900 casas fueron
evacuados y las llamas que han durado
más de un mes ya alcanzaron hasta las
remotas montañas de nuevo méjico las
conflagraciones están siendo más voraces
de lo habitual ante la prolongada sequía
en todo eeuu más de 5 mil 100 kilómetros
cuadrados se han quemado este año la
mayor cantidad desde 2018 en el mismo
período
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]